[Musique]
bonjour à l'automne 2022 la sobriété
était présentée par Emmanuel Macron et
son gouvernement comme la solution pour
faire face aux potentiel pénurie
énergétique lié à la guerre en Ukraine
la sobriété un concept repris au champ
de l'écologie politique qui la propose
depuis de nombreuses années pour faire
face aux dérèglement climatique on peut
penser par exemple au livre de Pierre
Rabhi la sobriété heureuse par une dès
2010 alors la sobriété est-ce que c'est
un pansement technique sur un problème
conjoncturel ou une vision de société
nous allons répondre à cette question
avec Jean-Marc chancovici et Yves
Marignac Jean-Marc Jancovici bonjour
vous êtes associé fondateur de carbone 4
société de conseils et de services sur
la transition bas carbone vous êtes
aussi président fondateur du shift
project un signe Tang qui travaille en
faveur d'une économie libérée de la
contrainte carbone
vous êtes aussi membre du Haut Conseil
pour le climat et en 2022 avec le
dessinateur Christophe blanc vous êtes
la personne qui a vendu le plus de
livres en France toute catégories de
confondues bref vous êtes un
vulgarisateur comme vous aimez le dire
XXL sur la question de l'énergie et du
climat il n'y a bonjour vous êtes un des
porte-parole de l'association négawat
vous êtes aussi expert du nucléaire
puisque vous êtes chef du pôle énergie
nucléaire et fossile de l'Institut négat
faut-il le rappeler une association à
but non lucratif qui réunit des experts
impliqués dans des activités
professionnelles liées à l'énergie
négaWatt existe depuis 2001 et je vais
rappeler la définition du mot negawat
terme qui désigne de manière globale
l'énergie non consommée ou économisée
par des actions de sobriété ou
d'efficacité énergétique c'est bien ça
c'est simple merci à vous deux d'avoir
accepté cet échange car pendant
longtemps pensé que vos chemins ne se
croiseraient jamais tels des parallèles
pour commencer déjà pour se mettre
d'accord on va parler du constat faire
une photo à l'instant en 2023 à
l'instant nous sommes avant d'exposer
vos arguments sur la transition l'un et
l'autre est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
quel est votre regard sur l'état de la
planète en termes de climat de
biodiversité quel regard portez-vous sur
l'état de notre terre Jean-Marc pour
commencer peut-être
le constat il est raisonnablement
partagé aujourd'hui il est pas très
difficile à faire
on a on en appartient à une espèce dans
le succès est en train de se retourner
contre elle c'est-à-dire que maintenant
avec 8 milliards de représentants sur
une planète qui n'a pas changé de
diamètre depuis que nous sommes apparus
dessus
nous utilisons de manière
minière ou linéaire un certain nombre de
ressources
et donc après utilisation ces ressources
ne sont plus disponibles dans ces
ressources on peut mettre les
hydrocarbures qui se détruisent par j'ai
envie de dire par construction quand on
s'en sert on peut également mettre un
certain nombre de ressources métalliques
qui là aussi sont difficilement
récupérables après usage on peut mettre
des ressources en sol initialement on
avait des écosystèmes sur les sols et on
les a supprimés pour faire autre chose
essentiellement des cultures
et puis on avait on peut dire également
comme ressources à un ensemble d'espèces
vivantes
dont les effectifs sont en effondrement
rapide encore pas plus tard que il y a
quelques jours il y avait un nouvel
article sur l'effondrement de la
population d'insectes dont la masse
combinée sur terre resterait pour le
moment encore égal à celle des hommes et
de leurs animaux domestiques un milliard
de tonnes
et puis on peut également mettre dans
les ressources le fait d'avoir eu un
climat stable le climat terrestre a
toujours varié au cours des heures
géologiques on a appris à l'école qu'il
y a eu des airs glaciaires qu'il y a eu
des dinosaures à un moment où vous êtes
beaucoup plus chaud que etc mais ça
faisait à peu près 10 000 ans
c'est-à-dire comme par hasard la durée
qui nous sépare de la sédentarisation de
notre espèce et des débuts de
l'agriculture pendant lesquels le climat
terrestre a été remarquablement stable
il a varié
moyenne n'a pas varié de plus d'une
fraction de degré sur les 10 000
dernières années et c'est ça qui a
permis notamment l'expansion humaine
c'est-à-dire l'adaptation génération
après génération à des conditions qui
elles ne varia pas s'il y avait varié
rapidement nous ne serions pas autour de
cette table voilà le moniteur aura connu
un destin différent et toutes ces
ressources sont mises en danger
aujourd'hui c'est à dire à moindre riz
en quantité ou à moins de riz en qualité
par notre activité
débordante débridée consistant
essentiellement à piocher tout ce qu'on
trouve dans l'environnement et à le
transformer pour en faire autre chose
comme par exemple la table sur laquelle
je suis en train de voter là l'immeuble
qui nous accueille les vêtements que
nous portons et l'électronique qui est
en train de nous filmer entre autre
chose
Yves vous partagez le constat oui
évidemment le tableau est assez complet
je crois effectivement il y a plus de
doute sur le fait que
le changement climatique est là
s'accélère que il est lié à nos
activités que les fondements de la
biodiversité malheureusement
l'accompagne que une action rapide et
nécessaire je crois personne ne remet en
cause notamment
l'idée de
d'atteindre une trajectoire de
réchauffement limité à 2 degrés et si
possible un degré 5 pour éviter des
dérèglements plus importants encore le
concept de l'anthropocène qu'on met
derrière ça et pas encore très stabilisé
mais on a bien quand même l'idée la
conscience que aujourd'hui l'espèce
humaine est arrivée par cette activité
débordante ou dévorante je ne sais pas
comment la qualifier à un point où elle
est capable
peut-être contre sa volonté ou en tout
cas de façon extrêmement contradictoire
de remettre en cause les conditions de
sa survie alors non pas en tant
qu'espèce très probablement mais de sa
survie en tant qu'espèce civilisée et
peut-être j'ajouterai au constat
justement cette dimension humaine
sociale économique c'est-à-dire que
c'est des règlements aujourd'hui ce
retourne contre nous d'ores et déjà de
façon assez brutale avec là toutes les
toutes les inégalités que ça peut
générer toutes les tensions et donc à
cette crise de la géosphère et de la
biosphère s'ajoutent clairement une
crise de nos sociétés de nos démocraties
d'accord alors face à ce constat un peu
sombre que vous portez tous les deux
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y a un
risque d'effondrement ou des
effondrement possible Jean-Marc
peut-être pour commencer alors le c'est
toujours difficile de donner un contenu
précis à des mots comme ça effondrement
moi je vais essayer de le définir un peu
plus précisément je suis tout à fait
d'accord sur le fait que la survie de
notre espèce n'est pas on n'est pas en
jeu mais enfin pour que l'espèce
survivre il suffit d'avoir quelques
millions de représentants vous savez
donc on n'a pas besoin du milliard pour
ça ce qui est en jeu aujourd'hui c'est
la c'est l'évolution de la taille de
l'humanité de son espérance de vie et de
ses conditions de vie c'est ça qui est
c'est ça qui est en jeu alors par
ailleurs l'humanité n'est pas un tout
homogène c'est-à-dire que l'évolution de
la de des conditions de vie elle est
déjà très différenciée aujourd'hui entre
ce qui peut se passer dans une ville
suédoise ce qui peut se passer dans une
campagne africaine et ce qui peut se
passer dans un bidon vie d'indien donc
dès à présent aujourd'hui les conditions
sont pas du tout homogènes et donc
traiter l'évolution de l'humanité future
comme un tout complètement homogène
c'est quelque chose qui ne correspond
pas à la réalité de ce qu'on observe ce
qui est sûr c'est que avec le temps il
va y avoir de façon croissante des
pressions qui vont s'exercer sur un
nombre croissant d'individus et qui vont
les conduire à avoir des conditions de
vie qui seront de manière croissante
dégradée par rapport à ce qu'ils
connaissait avant c'est ça qui c'est ça
qui est en train de se passer et c'est
ça qui malheureusement en ligne de pente
va continuer à prendre de l'ampleur
sur l'effondrement
je partage l'idée que
l'effondrement renvoie voilà beaucoup
beaucoup de d'images extrêmement
négatives peut générer aussi une sorte
de paralysie qui est évidemment
contre-productive par rapport aux
besoins d'agir
à
la situation comme comme celle d'une
mine de crête à suivre pour maintenir
justement les conditions de de
pérennité sous une forme ou une autre de
nos sociétés
éviter cette pente trop rapide et
aujourd'hui
effectivement le risque de chute d'une
manière ou d'une autre apparaît de plus
en plus évident
c'est
encore une fois c'est une ligne de crête
pour nous c'est à dire que on voit la
transition écologique comme une forme de
nécessité
qui doit nous permettre d'éviter des
bouleversements trop abruptes et et non
désiré mais clairement la crise que nous
avons connue qu'une connaissons encore
avec toutes les répercussions de la
situation en Ukraine les effets qui
commencent à être manifestent et violent
du dérèglement climatique et voilà
toutes les tensions qu'on peut observer
tout ça
participent de facteurs totalement
structurels et donc sans action
structurelles pour les résoudre ces
tensions ces inégalités et ses
difficultés vont s'accroître et quand on
parle de ligne de Crète c'est à la fois
une ligne de crête de plus en plus
étroite et difficile à trouver sur un
chemin démocratique évidemment de mise
en œuvre de ces transformations sur un
chemin économique à des énormes sujets
devant nous c'est évidemment la
transformation des modèles économiques
des entreprises dominantes qui
aujourd'hui nous entraînent dans dans
vers ces catastrophes et puis sur le
plan géopolitique là encore la situation
nous montre mais la transition
écologique c'est vis-à-vis de l'ensemble
de ces ressources que l'on extrait
aujourd'hui et qui font fonctionner
notre économie et qui sont
malheureusement mal à répartie et pas
répartie de façon homogène avec les
endroits où on les utilise la transition
écologique c'est des profonde de ces
interdépendances qui aujourd'hui crée là
aussi des obstacles très forts donc
voilà le risque est moins celui
d'un effondrement
brutal mécanique etc que celui d'une
inertie trop grande du système et des
décisions que l'on prend sur ces plans
démocratiques économiques et
géopolitique
voilà par rapport à un chemin qui existe
parce que c'est quand même ça aussi dans
le constat la bonne nouvelle d'une
certaine manière et le rapport du GIEC
de 2018 par exemple sur l'existence de
trajectoire un degré 5 le montrer c'est
que il reste possible de trouver des des
chemins
pour éviter cet effondrement ou quelques
quelques noms qu'on lui donne à
condition évidemment de changer
complètement de braquer par rapport à
l'urgence alors justement par rapport à
ces solutions que vous dressez là
déjà je suis content que vous partagiez
le constat tous les deux déjà une bonne
nouvelle
le concept de sobriété proposé par le
gouvernement Yves Marignac qui ne vous
parait suffisant pérenne où il est passé
structurel selon vous non il est
clairement pas assez structuré alors le
d'abord c'est quand même une bonne
nouvelle que le gouvernement se soit
saisi du terme de sobriété on se
souvient que il y a deux ans à peine je
crois le président de la République
assimilé la sobriété à la Société des
Amis je pour dire qu'il en était pas
question donc voilà ce sujet de la
sobriété c'est à dire une démarche
complémentaire de l'efficacité qui joue
plutôt sur les performances techniques
pour réduire les besoins en énergie la
sobriété jouant sur les usages sur voilà
la manière dont on dimensionne et choisi
les services que l'on demande à
l'énergie et aux ressources en général
j'ai inclus les matières premières les
sols tout ce que vous avez évoqué tout à
l'heure
cette voilà le fait même que la sobriété
soit à l'agenda et quand même une
nouvelle très positive après cette
sobriété est venue à l'agenda parce que
on était dans une forme d'urgence face à
la crise
liée à la situation ukrainienne et à une
défaillance inédite du parcours clair
cet hiver et effectivement dans les
quelques mois dont le gouvernement
disposait pour retrouver des marges la
sobriété qu'il a qu'il a appelé de ses
vœux était le seul levier possible et
d'ailleurs on a aujourd'hui un retour
d'expérience qui montre que ça a
fonctionné maintenant la sobriété qui
est nécessaire pour atteindre les
objectifs climatiques pour arrêter
l'érosion de la biodiversité et d'une
manière générale retrouver un système à
la fois
plus respectueux de ces limites
planétaires et de l'environnement et
plus juste socialement c'est une
subruité beaucoup plus structurelle et
là il y a énormément de pain sur la
planche et il y a pour rester dans le
champ politique une
contradiction énorme aujourd'hui dans le
discours du gouvernement et du président
de la République qui va bien falloir
résoudre puisque d'un côté Elizabeth
borne en présentant ce plan de sobriété
nous a dit que la sobriété devait
devenir structurelle et qu'il fallait
pérenniser donc des logiques de moindre
consommation mais dans le même temps le
président de la République expliquait
que le pays a besoin de continuer à
produire plus et que c'est une condition
notamment de maintien du modèle social
et on est évidemment en plein dans cette
actualité avec tout le questionnement
des mécanismes de distribution autour du
système des retraites Jean-Marc pour
compléter la question lorsque le
gouvernement a présenté son plan de
sobriété il annonçait un objectif de
réduction de 10% de la consommation
d'énergie alors qu'on doit faire
beaucoup plus donc est-ce que vous voyez
une forme aussi d'incohérence comme le
dit Yves Marignac je pense surtout qu'il
y a une forme de confusion autour du
terme
si on essaye de revenir à ce que
j'entends moi par la sobriété la
sobriété c'est le fait dans ma
définition avant de se priver
délibérément ou de renoncer délibérément
à un service histoire d'économiser
l'énergie et les matériaux qui vont avec
c'est quelque chose qui est forte
foncièrement différent de l'efficacité
qui ne conduit pas à se priver d'un
service mais qui conduit à disposer du
même service en ayant utilisé moins
d'énergie et moins de matière et c'est
fondamentalement différent de la
pauvreté qui est le fait de renoncer à
un service on voit parce que vous l'avez
choisi mais parce que les circonstances
extérieures vous l'imposent dans les
circonstances extérieures la plus
courante la plus classique c'est le
défaut de revenus alors je vais prendre
un exemple qui est un exemple très
bateau mais pour bien comprendre si vous
êtes dans un appartement et que vous
baissez le thermostat parce que vous
décidez de le faire pour le bien de la
planète et pour etc on est dans de la
sobriété si vous le baissez parce que
vous avez plus de quoi payer vos
factures alors que vous avez pas du tout
envie de le baisser vous êtes dans la
pauvreté et donc la seule différence sur
le plan physique il y a pas de
différence sur le plan physique entre la
pauvreté et la sobriété il y en a une
sur le plan mental c'est à dire que d'un
côté vous choisissez de l'autre côté
vous subissez
aujourd'hui dans le plan qui est
présenté par le gouvernement d'abord
c'est un plan qui repose beaucoup sur la
bonne volonté des individus donc de ce
point de vue on pourrait dire que c'est
de la sobriété effectivement puisque la
sobriété elle est par définition pour
moi choisie
mais par ailleurs c'est un plan qui n'a
pas d'efficacité garantie à partir du
moment où on dit aux gens ce serait
quand même bien que vous fassiez ça donc
ça veut dire que il faut vraiment qu'ils
en soi convaincus et qu'ils aient envie
de le faire
le plan mélange donc un peu l'efficacité
la sobriété la pauvreté et en fait la le
sa date d'apparition j'ai envie de dire
c'est quand même beaucoup il va falloir
de toute façon nous adapter à quelque
chose qu'on n'a pas choisi qui est un
défaut d'approvisionnement énergétique
dû aux événements en Ukraine entre autre
chose et effectivement du défaut de
production électrique en France
c'est donc là on est beaucoup plus dans
le registre de la pauvreté que dans le
registre de la sobriété parce que la
pauvreté encore une fois c'est une
réaction à un événement extérieur que
vous n'avez pas choisi
voilà donc après est-ce que ce plan il
est
global suffisant etc la réponse est non
mais ça c'est le cas de tous les plans
gouvernementaux qui ont été décidés avec
peu de préavis en réaction à des
événements extérieurs et effectivement
le gouvernement il est devant une forme
de quadrature du cercle qui est la
suivante la sobriété toute chose égale
par ailleurs elle est récessive
c'est-à-dire si vous décidez
délibérément d'acheter moins de
smartphone de baisser le thermostat
d'arrêter de prendre votre voiture et
prendre un vélo etc ça vous conduit par
construction à acheter moins de choses
donc ça conduit l'appareil à produire
économique à produire moins de choses
donc c'est récessif toute chose égale
par ailleurs encore une fois il faut
compter toujours l'échelle la même chose
de la même manière
à partir du moment où vous êtes dans un
contexte récessif l'État se retrouve
devant une équation impossible qui est
d'arriver à servir des demandes diverses
en augmentation on le voit en ce moment
avec les retraites on voudrait avoir à
la fois plus de retraite et plus de
salaire et plus de etc tout en ayant en
entrée moins de revenus pour le faire
parce que la comptabilité nationale est
implacable la production totale c'est
les revenus totaux par définition donc
il y a un vrai enfin comment dire le
pouvoir politique a toujours eu le cul
coincé entre deux chaises dans cette
histoire c'est que en fait il essaye de
réagir comme il peut à une contrainte
physique qui est la contrainte sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique tout en
ayant un souhait social
qui est encore aujourd'hui tout à fait
orthogonal à la réalité physique subit
ou que on essaye d'enclencher voilà et
aujourd'hui il a pas trouvé la solution
à cette équation impossible
et le monde économique au sens
académique n'a pas non plus la solution
à cette équation impossible c'est à dire
que si vous essayez de regarder où sont
les gens qui essayent opérationnellement
de comprendre comment est-ce qu'on gère
un monde en décrue économique vous
n'avez rien vous avez quelques personnes
qui disent il faudrait le faire mais ces
personnes aujourd'hui n'ont pas c'est
pas une critique c'est juste un constat
non pas la réponse à la question très
pratique par exemple qui est comment je
gère un système de retraite par
répartition dans un monde en
décroissance
il y a pas
ce cahier des charges n'existe nulle
part et donc personne n'y réfléchi voilà
donc c'est c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
on est dans cette espèce de de
contradiction apparente dans le discours
public entre selon le jour et l'heure
une déclaration en faveur de moins et
une déclaration en faveur de plus voilà
c'est ça qui explique que aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de cohérence d'ensemble
derrière ça qui sont le lien entre la
sobriété telle qu'on peut l'envisager de
façon positive c'est-à-dire un meilleur
choix effectivement des services
énergétiques rendus et on y inclut nous
à negawa qui comprit l'augmentation des
services quand on lutte contre la
précarité énergétique
amener des ménages qui aujourd'hui ne
peuvent pas se chauffer à pouvoir le
faire fait partie d'une politique
globale de sobriété même si il y a une
contradiction apparente dans les termes
donc il y a la question de la justice
sociale il y a la question du rapport à
la croissance ou peut-être plus
exactement la création de valeur du côté
de la justice sociale
on se réfère nous de plus en plus avec
Megawatt en lien d'ailleurs avec la
définition que le GIEC donne maintenant
à donner dans son sixième rapport
d'évaluation de la sobriété à la logique
les amis du donut qui parle d'un espace
économique sur et juste pour l'humanité
peut-être préciser c'est quoi le donut
donc justement c'est c'est l'idée de
placer notre économie dans un espace
juste et sûr en forme de beignets d'où
le nom de cette théorie avec une limite
supérieure qui est celle des limites
planétaires donc de la physique qui
s'impose à nous en termes de ressources
et de capacité de notre planète à
absorber des des pollutions et des
émissions mais aussi une limite
inférieure un plancher et c'était
essentiel de conditions de vie décente
pour tous on est évidemment très loin à
l'échelle mondiale vous parliez des
bidonvilles en Inde je crois tout à
l'heure il y a énormément à faire dans
ce domaine et la sobriété dans cette
vision là c'est à la fois un principe de
modération collective pour effectivement
rester dans les mines dans les limites
mais aussi un principe de redistribution
et donc il y a un lien très fort à
établir entre la sobriété et l'équité
dans un pays comme le nôtre ou la
solidarité au niveau international et
c'est une des dimensions qui manquait
cruellement dans le plan du gouvernement
qui a refusé en fait d'introduire toute
logique de différenciation dans les
signaux dans les mesures proposées on
appelle effectivement au pouvoir de
chacun alors qu'il y a une très forte
demande de la population pour dire il
faudrait quand même cibler des efforts
du côté des des modes de consommation
qui sont de manière évidente les moins
vertueuses ça c'était par exemple
focalisé sur la question des jets privés
donc il y a un lien à faire
politiquement entre cette question de la
sobriété et de la justice sociale qui
n'est pas fait aujourd'hui et puis le
deuxième sujet parce que c'est
évidemment de ça qui va dépendre la
capacité redistributive c'est qu'est-ce
qui effectivement crée de la valeur
aujourd'hui nos indicateurs économiques
considèrent par exemple que un geste qui
est
l'antithèse de la sobriété qui est de
laisser la lumière allumée dans les
toilettes quand on en sort et valoriser
en termes économique ça participe de la
croissance du Pipe donc il y a vraiment
un travail à faire sur ce qui crée
effectivement de la valeur sur la
manière dont l'économie ne paye pas la
destruction de ressources et la
dégradation dans l'environnement et
voilà changer les indicateurs changer
les modèles d'affaires tant qu'on sera
enfermé dans ce paradigme d'une
croissance
au sens d'une création de valeur adossée
à un modèle productiviste je pense qu'on
serait effectivement confronté à cette
quadrature du cercle impossible dans
laquelle le gouvernement est enfermé
aujourd'hui là on va revenir un peu plus
tard à cette question du changement de
pardon mais je voudrais qu'on reste sur
les solutions selon différentes études
pour rester sous une augmentation de 1
degré 5 nous devons laisser entre 60 et
80% des énergies fossiles dans le sol
peut-on imaginer une société sans dérivé
de pétrole ou sans pétrole du tout
Jean-Marc on peut aussi l'imaginer
puisque ça a été le cas de la société
dans laquelle notre espèce a vécu
jusqu'à il y a deux siècles donc
imaginez une société voire des sociétés
dans lesquelles on se passe
d'hydrocarbures bien sûr que c'est
possible la question c'est avec quelle
contrepartie aujourd'hui quand on
regarde les scénarios qui sont produits
pour imaginer un monde à 1,5 degrés
c'est tous des scénarios de croissance
économique c'est-à-dire que quand vous
regardez les scénarios à 1,5 degrés qui
sont rassemblés par le GIEC alors je
rappelle que le GIEC ne fait pas trop
cher le GIEC se contente de compiler et
de synthétiser ce qui paraît dans la
littérature à comité de lecture sur une
discipline donnée par qui sont fait les
scénarios macroscopiques essentiellement
par des gens qui travaillent dans le
monde économique
les gens qui travaillent dans le monde
économique ils utilisent tous tous un
PIB qui est exogène c'est à dire que les
modèles économiques qu'on utilise
aujourd'hui dans le monde ne vous
donnent pas le PIB comme une variable de
sortie c'est une variable d'entrée alors
quand c'est pas le PIB directement qui
est une variable d'entrée c'est la
productivité du travail mais ça revient
au même
donc tous les scénarios vous irez
regarder les familles de scénario que
Ikea dans le cas dans le GIEC y compris
les scénario 1,5 degrés sont des
scénarios dans lesquels la croissance
économique continue jusqu'à l'échéance
du scénario c'est à dire que les
économistes qui ont fait ce travail ils
postulent que dans un monde avec de
moins en moins de machines au travail
puisque c'est ça un de moins en moins
d'énergie on va quand même avoir de plus
en plus de production
aux améliorations techniques près ça
veut dire que tous tous les processus
physiques qui sont émetteurs de gaz à
effet de serre baisse
et quand on regarde la vitesse à
laquelle on devrait introduire des
améliorations strictement techniques sur
la fabrication de l'acier sur la
production de l'électricité des
carbonées sur les transports sur etc
pour avoir des émissions qui baissent à
la bonne vitesse tout en conservant la
production physique qu'on a aujourd'hui
je ne connais personne qui arrive à
proposer quelque chose de probant j'ai
jamais vu
parce que effectivement on peut faire
des améliorations techniques mais la
question c'est à quelle échelle à quelle
vitesse etc
sans compter qu'il y a des il y a des
sujets de bouclage par exemple
aujourd'hui pour faire n'importe quel
objet vous bénéficiez de la productivité
industrielle amenée par les combustibles
fossiles et la facilité avec laquelle on
continuerait à faire ces objets qu'il
s'agisse d'une batterie d'une éolienne
d'une centrale nucléaire ou d'un
porte-conteneur peu importe dans un
monde dans lequel il y a plus les
combustibles fossiles est une question
qui aujourd'hui n'est pas résolue non
plus par les économistes c'est-à-dire
que personne ne sait répondre à cette
question absolument personne
tout simplement donc on peut très bien
imaginer un monde dans lequel on s'est
débarrassé des combustibles fossiles mon
analyse c'est que ça se situe n'importe
où entre la civilisation qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui et ce qu'on avait à la fin
de la Renaissance voilà n'importe où
entre les deux donc je dis pas que c'est
la fin c'est quelque part entre les deux
et aujourd'hui les les outils encore une
fois de simulation globale qui sont
utilisées même aussi project ne
permettent pas de répondre à la question
de savoir où exactement on serait entre
les deux parce que il ne traite pas de
la question de la baisse de la
productivité du travail dans un monde
dans lequel on a de moins en moins de
combustibles fossiles il ne traite pas
de cette question là avant qu'on ait les
combustibles fossiles la marine
marchande c'était des bateaux à voile
alors c'était bien pour transporter de
la soie des pierres précieuses et du thé
mais c'est pas avec ça qu'on
transportait du minerai de fer et du
Pétrole partout à la surface de la
planète avant le pétrole on n'avait pas
de camion donc on avait des charrettes
aveux et quelques trains c'était très
bien pour transporter un peu de blé un
peu de bois un peu de charbon à droite
et à gauche mais ça permettait pas de
transporter partout à la surface de la
planète les fringues et les choux-fleurs
pour le prix qu'on les paye dans les
villes etc donc en France par exemple un
camion sur trois transportent un truc
qui se mange bon
donc avant les combustibles fossiles en
fait on avait un monde qui était
extrêmement différent du monde dans
lequel nous vivons aujourd'hui et quand
on regarde la dépendance au combustible
fossiles y compris dans des objets qui
nous sert à nécessaire pour consommer
moins on se rend compte qu'on a un
système totalement imbriqué totalement
asservie et aujourd'hui c'est
extrêmement difficile d'avoir des outils
qui permettent
dans un monde qui aurait beaucoup moins
de combustible fossiles de comprendre
l'effet global qui sort donc on peut
faire des plans nous on a fait aussi
projets on a fait un plan un plan de
transformation de l'économie française
même ce plan-là reste incomplet parce
que l'effet que je viens d'évoquer on
n'est pas capable de le traiter
aujourd'hui de manière satisfaisante
donc on a des idées du reste
convergentes avec Megawatt sur un
certain nombre de points des directions
dans lesquelles partir mais définir le
point d'arrivée aujourd'hui je soutiens
que personne n'en est capable
et j'ai peut-être compléter la question
et est-ce que la croissance verte c'est
ça reste un mythe un leurre
c'est c'est
un mauvais termes qui ne permet pas de
poser correctement les enjeux et je
partage assez assez fortement la manière
dont
il vient de le faire on est
effectivement
confronté à la nécessité de oui sortir
d'une économie qui encore une fois créer
de la valeur par toujours plus de
production matérielle c'est ça c'est ça
l'enjeu alors il faut en plus le faire
si on se replace dans une perspective
mondiale en continuant malgré tout à
créer de la production au sens classique
du terme dans des pays notamment les
pays qu'on appelle toujours publiquement
en voie de développement ou le retard à
rattrapé et quand même colossal donc
raison de plus pour effectivement
interroger d'autant plus la manière dont
on a dans des pays comme le nôtre on
consomme aujourd'hui c'est là que la
sobriété est essentielle il faut revenir
à la notion de service et regarder
comment on peut trouver en plus
évidemment de l'amélioration technique
des ressorts de d'amélioration sur la
mobilité par exemple il y a d'abord le
fait d'aller vers de la mobilité
électrique qui un est plus efficace et
deux et plus facilement des
carbonarables je pense que c'est un
constat qu'on partage mais si on le fait
à ISO system du point de vue de
l'organisation de notre mobilité du
choix de nos véhicules on va continuer à
rouler l'essentiel du temps à 30 km/h en
ville seul dans une berline totalement
surdimensionnée avec tous les effets de
consommation de matière de d'usage des
sols etc que ça peut emporter donc il
faut en fait combiner ça avec le fait
d'aller vers ce que les experts
appellent la mobilité cervicielle c'est
à dire le fait de pouvoir utiliser
autant que possible des véhicules
différents en fonction en fonction des
usages pour en ville ne plus utiliser
que des petits véhicules
à la bonne dimension et puis il faut
augmenter leur taux de remplissage
les routes françaises alors de pointe
c'est des dizaines de millions de sièges
vides qui circulent dans dans nos
voitures et puis il faut évidemment
faire du report modal et donc vers les
transports collectifs et vers les
mobilités quand on regarde d'un point de
vue physique les trajectoires possibles
dans ce domaine en prenant en compte
l'inertie nécessaire des transformations
en prenant en compte les ressources
nécessaires
à negawat on a une modélisation qui
couvre l'ensemble de l'empreinte en
matière première de l'économie française
donc on est très attentif à la manière
dont les choses boucles de ce point de
vue là entre aujourd'hui et 2050
on sait effectivement écrire des
trajectoires physiques compatibles avec
avec les enjeux en tout cas c'est
vraiment notre notre conviction forte et
aujourd'hui il y a différents scénarios
qui convergent autour de ça d'ailleurs
on peut observer par rapport au fait que
les modélisations
sont été en tout cas essentiellement
économiques autour de ces sujets que de
plus en plus elle colle et c'est
l'approche du chiffre project avec son
son plein de transformation de
l'économie française c'est l'approche de
RTE c'est l'approche de l'ADEME
aujourd'hui elle à une modélisation de
plus en plus physique pourquoi parce
qu'effectivement la modélisation
économique elle est enfermée dans un
paradigme autour de la croissance et
autour de cet enjeu clé de la
productivité du travail nous on a fait
évaluer le scénario Mégawat par des
modèles de ce type il donne des
résultats positifs le scénariote c'est
un modèle ou dans le bien que mal le PIB
augmente en France et même il augmente
plus que dans un scénario tendance sauf
que ça repose sur une hypothèse de
continuité linéaire de la production de
la des progrès de la productivité du
travail donc qui est voilà un truc
interne au modèle et donc personne en
fait ne sait rien donc tant qu'on n'aura
pas interrogé au fond et les économistes
ont un rôle majeur à jouer dans ce
domaine l'évolution de la productivité
l'évolution de la création de valeur
dans un système où c'est l'intelligence
de service
qui est valorisé plutôt que la
destruction sans la payer de ressources
on sera on sera effectivement coincé
dans un modèle économique qui nous
permet pas de mettre en oeuvre les
trajectoires dont on sait aujourd'hui
que physiquement elles sont possibles
donc là vous êtes en train de dire qu'il
est possible d'imaginer un découplage
entre les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et la croissance
en fait
la croissance telle qu'elle est mesurée
aujourd'hui probablement pas la
croissance au sens d'une création de
valeur et
d'un maintien à minima des conditions
sociales actuelles voire d'un progrès je
pense que c'est possible en actionnant
l'ensemble des leviers de sobriété
d'efficacité et de décarbonation de la
production sur ce découplage Jean-Marc
je pense que c'est on fait ce qu'on veut
je veux dire par là
rien ne nous empêche conventionnellement
de valoriser l'émission que nous sommes
en train de faire 10% de plus chaque
année en expliquant que c'est quelque
chose qui amène une valeur ajoutée qui
vaut bien 10% de plus chaque année au
moins voilà donc je pense qu'on fait
exactement ce qu'on veut en termes de
valorisation de la production on peut
aussi dire quelque chose que voilà le
poireau de l'année prochaine qui coûtera
plus cher que le poireau de cette année
en fait il a poussé dans une atmosphère
un peu plus chargée en CO2 donc en fait
c'est pas le même poireau donc si vos
10% de plus moi c'est son vrai prix il y
a pas besoin de le corriger de
l'inflation et donc on peut faire
exactement ce qu'on veut
la vraie question en fait c'est comment
est-ce qu'on va arriver à s'organiser
avec physiquement moins de choses en
fait c'est ça la vraie question c'est
pour ça qu'on a commencé par traiter
cette question là dans le plan de
transformation de l'économie française
on a fait effectivement un on a commencé
une approche physique de l'économie qui
est loin d'être terminée donc c'est un
début c'est voilà on est parfaitement
conscient du fait que c'est le premier
pas et que c'est on espère entraîner
d'autres personnes dans cette direction
immobilise d'autres cervelles dans la
même direction pour que voilà on est
plus de ressources affectées à comment
est-ce qu'on traite l'économie sous un
angle physique et ce qui est vraiment
limitant dans l'économie pour nous c'est
les ressources physiques et les
compétences d'accord donc c'est ça les
deux c'est ça les deux facteurs qui sont
vraiment limitants après économiquement
conventionnellement on fait un peu ce
qu'on veut
par contre ce qui est vraiment important
c'est que du point de vue de nos
habitudes de consommation à partir du
moment où on dit qu'on va s'organiser
avec moins c'est comment est-ce qu'on
s'organise alors prenons l'exemple des
déplacements qui vient d'être évoqué si
on a moins de matériaux à notre
disposition pour nous déplacer ça veut
dire qu'on va globalement faire le
chemin inverse de celui qu'on a fait sur
les 60 derniers ou 80 dernières années
je vous rappelle qu'en 1945 il y avait
en France 2,5 millions de voitures on
est aujourd'hui pas loin de 40 millions
donc c'est 40 millions de voitures c'est
autant de tonnes d'acier autant de
tonnes de pétrole autant etc alors on a
moins d'acier moins de pétrole qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on va avoir globalement moins
de voitures et moins de kilomètres en
voiture c'est ça le vrai sujet parce que
à partir du moment où on a moins de
voitures et moins de kilomètres en
voiture que devient la valeur économique
des habitats en banlieue que devient
l'univers de choix pour travailler de la
personne qui habite aujourd'hui à 30
bornes de son travail et qui ne peut pas
covoiturer avec quelqu'un d'autre parce
qu'il y a personne d'autre qui habite au
même endroit et qui va à la même heure
ou même endroit pour bosser c'est non
mais c'est ça les vraies questions
savoir si la bagnole elle vaut la moitié
du prix ou deux fois le prix c'est pas
le sujet le sujet c'est que si vous en
avez moins comment est-ce qu'on
s'organise il y a une question supra
même qu'on n'a pas traité dans le plan
de transformation de l'économie
française c'est est-ce que on a toujours
besoin de conurbation à 10 millions
d'habitants dans un monde sobre en
énergie ma réponse est non ma réponse
c'est que ce genre de truc ça flotte pas
dans un monde sobre en énergie parce que
aujourd'hui quand vous regardez quelle
est l'interlande de la région parisienne
c'est le monde entier
vous portez et je porte des ressources
en matière de vêtements qui viennent de
l'autre côté du monde le coton que vous
portez là il a pas poussé en
Île-de-France et les fibres synthétiques
qui font ma fourrure polaire n'ont pas
été extraites en Île-de-France je vais
manger à midi attention de manger à midi
c'est très mal
de de des produits qui sont faits avec
du gaz qui vient de l'autre côté de la
planète qui ont été fertilisés avec de
la potasse et des phosphates qui
viennent du Maroc et je sais pas où
qui ont été cultivés avec une tracteur
qui a une qui est fait en acier qui
vient de l'autre côté de la planète
aussi enfin dont je vais manger de la
mondialisation je suis vêtu de
mondialisation j'habite dans la
mondialisation je me déplace grâce à la
mondialisation parce que c'est pareil le
métro parisien ou la marche à pied dans
Paris la marche à pied dans Paris c'est
sur du bitume à nouveau du pétrole qui
vient de je sais pas où donc en fait on
se rend pas compte mais une ville comme
Paris et n'importe quelle grande ville
de France aujourd'hui elle est plongée
dans la mondialisation et sans cette
espèce d'interlande qui va jusque de
l'autre côté de la planète elle ne vit
pas l'électronique est en train de nous
filmer en ce moment c'est pareil c'est
un enfant de la si on devait faire cet
électronique avec juste il y a 40 métaux
différents là dans la caméra qui est en
train de me filmer si on devait faire
cette caméra juste avec des ressources
françaises et de l'énergie française on
la ferait pas à votre métier
n'existerait pas et du reste le mien non
plus parce que consultant c'est
insufflétif de l'informatique donc il
faut bien voir que aujourd'hui on vit
dans un monde qui est totalement plongé
dans la mondialisation et par de la même
et c'est très très difficile je dis bien
c'est très très difficile donc c'est pas
une critique contre négaWatt c'est pas
une critique contre les équipes du
chiffre project de faire une
modélisation couplée globale qui
tiennent compte de la démondialisation à
laquelle on va avoir droit dans un monde
qui va devenir de plus en plus sobre en
énergie économiquement personne n'est
foutu de faire ça et même physiquement
c'est quelque chose qui est très
compliqué à faire donc il y a des poches
dans lesquelles on sait que on peut
raisonner je vais pas dire toutes choses
égales par ailleurs mais on voit à peu
près donc à structure urbaine comparable
on sait effectivement que tous les gens
qui se déplacent chaque jour de moins de
10 ou 15 km seul en bagnole bah ils
peuvent se déplacer en vélo électrique
mais ça suppose que les emplois qu'ils
font restent disponibles dans un monde
qui est plus sobre en énergie mais ça
suppose etc ce qui est pas du tout
assuré donc on voit bien aujourd'hui que
pour faire le grand tout en termes de
modélisation c'est vraiment très très
compliqué on pourrait au moins y penser
qualitativement et rien que ça
aujourd'hui on est très en dessous des
modes de raisonnement qui continuent à
être utilisés alors justement là pour
rester dans le très concret je vais vous
donner à parole Yves vous avez parlé
essentiellement du transport mais pour
décarboner les l'économie ou en tout cas
la société sur quel poste on pour réagir
aujourd'hui vers la sobriété le logement
l'agriculture l'alimentation en fait il
faut agir sur tous les postes c'est bien
ça la difficulté mais j'ajouterai à ce
qui vient d'être dit la question de
l'adaptation de nos infrastructures ou
des règlements en cours qui vaut
notamment pour les énormes
agglomérations comme comme Paris et la
synchronisation
puisque c'est dérèglement là viennent
vite et que l'évidence nos
infrastructures ne sont pas adaptées je
pense à la fois à la question climatique
et à la question de l'effondrement de la
biodiversité dont on est aujourd'hui
très loin je pense de projeter tous les
effets systémiques en cascade par
rapport à ça il y a en tout cas même si
je partage complètement le constat sur
le fait que
imaginer ces trajectoires de façon
bouclée aujourd'hui à l'échelle
française déjà c'est compliqué
européenne mondiale puisque il faut le
poser à l'échelle mondiale et
extrêmement difficile et il y a il y a
un champ disait il faut que les
économistes s'y collent oui il faut que
l'ensemble des des experts qui font de
la prospective qui réfléchissent à ces
questions et qui font des modèles
intègre pleinement ça on est en fait on
continue à fonctionner avec des modèles
qui ont été construits dans les trentes
glorieuses en France etc avec des images
de système qui voilà continuent sur
s'annoncer sans sans rien ne le fasse
dériver par rapport à tout ça donc même
si on est très loin d'avoir une vision
complète bouclée de l'ensemble il y a
quand même des actions qui sont sans
regret le transfert modal par le
développement d'infrastructures
permettant plus de mobilité douce ou de
transport collectif le fait d'organiser
l'offre automobile pour aller vers des
véhicules plus petits plus tôt que
d'aller vers des segments SUV de plus en
plus luxueux etc ça c'est des actions
sans regret il faut pour leur donner de
la cohérence pouvoir les inscrire dans
des plans à long terme c'est tout toute
la nécessité de scénarios comme comme
ceux que qu'on essaie de produire pour
informer le débat public mais la
sobriété dans les différents secteurs et
les sans regret donc dans le domaine de
la mobilité on en a parlé dans le
domaine du logement il y a un enjeu
central à maîtriser les surfaces
globale par habitant alors c'est pas
simple c'est faire évoluer l'offre de
logement dans le scénario nagawat par
exemple on fait progressivement diminuer
la part de maison individuelle neuves
pour stabiliser à l'horizon 2050 le la
part entre logement collectif et maison
individuelle dans le neuf on joue sur la
taille des nouveaux logements ou sur ce
qu'on appelle le taux de décohabitation
c'est à dire le nombre moyen de
personnes par logement pour stabiliser
voire réduire un peu les mètres carrés
chauffés par personne à l'horizon 2050
là non plus c'est pas simple quand je
dis
stabiliser le taux de décohabitation ça
veut dire évidemment non pas intervenir
sur la manière dont les familles vivent
mais ça veut dire imaginer des
politiques d'encouragement à la
colocation d'étudiants à la location
d'une chambre par un jeune travailleur
dans un pavillon qui n'est plus occupé
que une personne
âgée seule etc donc il y a énormément de
choses à faire dans ce domaine qui sont
complexes il y a tout le champ de
l'alimentation il faut d'abord du point
de vue des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre réduire la part carnet de notre
alimentation et il faut réduire la part
transformée et limiter les gaspillages
je crois 40% de la production agricole à
vos questions alimentaires 30% et perdu
aujourd'hui
et il faut aussi s'attaquer à la
consommation de bien
et lutter contre l'obsolescence
programmée lutter contre la
multiplication de nos équipements et nos
appareils globalement tout ça ça appelle
à ce que on nomme un négawat une offre
de sobriété c'est-à-dire une vraie
intervention des pouvoirs publics pour
réguler les marchés pour créer les
infrastructures nécessaires il faut
sortir d'une logique ou tout ça ne
relève que des éco-gestes et des
changements de comportement il faut
vraiment créer les conditions pour que
ces changements soient possibles alors
je vous en parlez beaucoup dans votre BD
sur entre l'alimentation
les fringues qu'est-ce qui vous paraît
le poste le plus important
être le plus sobre l'intérieur de notre
cervelle
en fait le point important c'est est-ce
que on arrive à se faire se faire une
idée du bonheur en se disant que on va
acheter de moins en moins souvent à
smartphone plutôt que de l'acheter de
plus en plus souvent
que on va le garder le plus longtemps
possible que on va le choisir avec les
performances les plus modestes possibles
parce que c'est pas la peine d'en avoir
plus c'est ça c'est ça le vrai sujet et
pareil pour les vêtements et pareil pour
la voiture c'est un truc pour se
déplacer mais c'est aussi un objet
statut social sinon les gens
achèteraient pas autant de SUV donc je
pense pas que la hauteur des trottoirs
est considérablement augmentée ces
derniers temps et que bon donc la c'est
l'intérieur de nos cervelles le le vrai
sujet alors il se trouve que
on a des comportements peu importe s'il
y a une structure cérébrale ou pas
auquel l'attribuer dans la BD on a on a
parlé du striatum mais c'est un clin
d'oeil c'est pas on n'est pas biologiste
on sait pas si c'est là ou si c'est
ailleurs mais peu importe c'est presque
un nom de code j'ai envie de dire mais
le fait est que quand on observe le
comportement on se rend compte que on
sait historiquement toujours comporté
comme des animaux accumulatifs que on
sait très facilement s'organiser pour
avoir plus que c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué de s'organiser pour avoir
moins
ou en tout cas c'est pas quelque chose
de spontané chez nous
et donc le vrai sujet c'est l'intérieur
de nos cervelles à partir du moment où à
l'intérieur de nos cervelles on se dit
que ça peut correspondre à une forme
d'optimum
et en fait pour ça il faut toujours que
on est plus à court terme ou à moyen
terme en face du moins qu'on va
abandonner si je reprends l'exemple
voiture versus vélo
la seule manière de faire en sorte que
les gens se mettent au vélo c'est pas
tellement de leur dire qu'ils vont avoir
moins parce que ça c'est compliqué c'est
de leur dire qu'ils vont avoir plus dans
certains domaines où la voiture le
ramène pas donc ils vont avoir plus de
bien-être parce que ils sont un peu
moins stressés ils vont pas être dans
les bouchons ils vont faire un peu
d'exercice ils trouveront ça plutôt
sympa et ils vont pas avoir le problème
de se garer au lieu de destination parce
que c'est quand même beaucoup plus
facile de se garer à vélo donc il faut
leur vendre et que ils vont être en
meilleure forme et que ils vont pouvoir
impressionner le voisin la voisine leurs
enfants ou qui sais-je et ben si vous
leur vendez ce genre de truc vous avez
plus de chance d'y arriver que de leur
dire c'est pas bien de prendre la
voiture c'est bon donc on a on a le
problème qui est à l'intérieur de nos
cervelles c'est exactement pareil pour
les régimes alimentaires moi les régimes
alimentaires quand on dit faut arrêter
de manger de la viande et manger des
galettes de tofu desséché je suis désolé
j'ai vraiment pas envie quoi bon donc
c'est c'est on est quand même des
animaux qui agissons sous l'emprise de
la séduction sinon il y aurait pas de
mode il y aurait pas on est
essentiellement fait de choses
affectives c'est comme ça que que il
nous arrive parfois de dire qu'on est
des animaux rationnels et moi je
soutiens pas du tout on est des animaux
qui pilotent rationnellement nos désirs
mais c'est ça qu'on fait mais on n'est
pas du tout des animaux rationnels donc
si on veut que la sobriété devienne une
réalité
ça veut dire que il faut pas seulement
qu'on ait des constructions techniques
qui répondent à ça il faut qu'on ait des
constructions alors appelons-le comme on
veut moral politique
affective religieuse je sais pas enfin
mais quelque chose qui est pas du tout
du domaine de la de la de la technique
mais quelque chose qui est du domaine
plus généralement des valeurs et sachant
que le débat sur les valeurs elles sont
à des va difficiles parce que
voilà
mais il faut commencer par ça j'ai envie
de dire et après techniquement c'est on
sait enfin je veux dire il sait je sais
plein plein de choses sur la façon de
s'organiser avec moi
par exemple si je prends l'exemple de
l'électronique on sait comment
s'organiser avec moins il faut revenir à
une à la tarification des débits
histoire de faire baisser ces derniers
il faut allonger les durées légales de
garantie de manière extrêmement forte de
telle sorte que l'obsolescence soit un
coup pour le producteur au lieu d'être à
bénéfice et il faut encourager dans un
certain nombre de domaines à ce qu'on ne
diffuse pas du numérique par exemple la
diffusion du numérique à l'école je
considère que c'est une c'est quelque
chose qu'il faut pas faire en tout cas
sûrement pas à l'école primaire et
probablement pas au collège etc donc il
y a un certain nombre de choses qui sont
on sait ce qu'il faut faire la bonne
question c'est comment on se donne envie
d'y arriver alors on va finir je pense
être entretien par cette question de
changement de personnel Patrick vivrait
philosophe disait pas de changement de
société sans changement personnel mais
avant j'ai encore quelques questions
techniques vous me parlez vous
pardonnerez
sur deux trois points donc on a bien
compris que pour décarboner l'économie
on devait changer nos Modalités mais on
aura toujours besoin un peu d'énergie et
donc on va arriver à la question
peut-être qui va vous faire peut-être
des petites questions diverses et
d'autres à travers vos arguments mais
chez nagawatt vous préconisez un
scénario 100% renouvelable est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui avec le peu de
d'équipement qu'on a en France sur
l'énergie renouvelable 20% est-ce que
c'est envisageable de tenir ce scénario
alors ça nous paraît un tout à fait
envisageable et absolument indispensable
alors je laisse de côté la question de
du nucléaire existant et de à quel
rythme on ferme le parking existant
notre point de vue sur ce sur cette
question et que il y a une pyramide des
âges du parc qui fait que si on repousse
indéfiniment les fermetures on sera
confronté à un rythme trop brutal
difficilement gérable et que donc il
faut anticiper et lisser autant que
possible ces fermetures pour ne pas se
condamner à devoir faire fonctionner les
réacteurs à
au-delà de ce que la sûreté à un moment
mettrait comme limite donc mais ça c'est
le parc actuel sur les la question des
nouveaux moyens de production il me
semble nous assez évident aujourd'hui un
que les renouvelables se déploient
beaucoup plus vite de quels sont plus
compétitives que le nouveau nucléaire
enfin les OPR 2 dont parle le
gouvernement c'est pas avant 2035 2037
donc c'est trop tard par rapport à
l'urgence climatique il me semble aussi
que le chemin technique vers 100%
renouvelable dans l'électricité est
aujourd'hui bien balisé à travers
l'ensemble des innovations et des
potentiels qui s'ouvrent que ce soit du
côté de la flexibilité de la demande que
ce soit du côté des différentes
solutions de stockage à différentes
échelles d'énergie et de temps
et que ce soit du côté plus technique de
la tenue en tension et en fréquence du
réseau donc ce chemin pour nous c'est
voilà aujourd'hui une évidence quand on
le projette au niveau mondial c'est non
seulement une évidence mais c'est une
nécessité c'est à dire que
les les personnes qui aujourd'hui disent
que
nucléaire est nécessaire en France parce
que le 100% renouvelable ne serait pas
possible doivent nous expliquer comment
le 100% renouvelable ne serait pas
possible dans d'autres pays où le
déploiement du nucléaire ne semble pas
envisageable donc atteindre le 100%
renouvelable ailleurs et nécessaire et
du coup il devient possible en France je
rappelle que le scénario neutralité
carbone de l'Agence internationale de
l'énergie c'est 90% de renouvelables
dans la production d'électricité qui
double ou plus que ça entre aujourd'hui
et 2050
90% de renouvelables ça veut évidemment
dire que dans certaines régions du monde
on est sur sur 100% donc voilà c'est
possible ça nous paraît évidemment
désirable compte tenu des risques
associés au nucléaire et puis dernier
point il y a évidemment tout l'argument
de la densité énergétique relative du
nucléaire et des renouvelables et sur ce
sur ce plan là
ben c'est l'intérêt d'avoir un scénario
bouclé en termes de d'empreinte matière
première ce qu'on constate c'est que un
scénario comme megawatts est un scénario
de baisse de 20 à 30% de l'empreinte
matière première en général et que dans
l'empreinte qui reste les renouvelables
ne représentent que un Pouillet m'a 7 8
10% au grand maximum sur certains
matériaux qui donc les ordres de
grandeur et les enjeux du point de vue
des matières premières se situent
ailleurs que dans ce secteur alors
Jean-Marc vous vous dites dans votre BD
que ça prend beaucoup de place qu'on
aura besoin beaucoup d'éoliennes qu'on
aura besoin de matériaux comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure et finalement
vous croyez assez peu au projet de
nagawatt ou celui de RTU qui est 100%
renouvelable est-ce que vous pouvez nous
préciser qu'est-ce qui vous freine dans
cette vision du tout renouvelable
alors ce que
je vais commencer par un point qui a été
évoqué par une Marignac qui est la
question du risque
il y a une raison généralement invoquée
dans les scénarios qui se passent du
nucléaire qui est la question du risque
qui arrive en premier c'est il faut s'en
passer parce que c'est une énergie trop
risquée
personnellement je ne souscris pas cette
analyse c'est à dire que toutes les
activités industrielles que nous avons
sont risquées et les renouvelables au
sens où on les entend dans des scénarios
de déploiement massif sont également des
activités industrielles si les questions
de fabriquer des dizaines des centaines
de milliers d'éoliennes et de
panneaux solaires ça reste une activité
industrielle ça va avec des activités
minières qui sont des activités risquées
ça va avec des activités de transport
qui sont aussi parfois des activités
risquées donc il y a aussi des risques
personnellement quand il y a une analyse
de risque la première personne vers
laquelle je me tourne pour savoir si
quelque chose est risqué ou pas c'est
les gens qui ont fait des qui ont
regardé les choses de près et qui sont
dans des disciplines qui sont à même de
donner un avis alors sur les risques en
ce qui concerne le nucléaire il y a deux
catégories de gens qui donnent des avis
il y a des médecins pour les risques
liés à l'exploitation en conditions
normales ou aux accidents et puis les
biologistes exactement pour les mêmes
les mêmes choses et quand on regarde ce
que ces gens-là publient
ils ne disent pas que le nucléaire est
une horreur absolue voilà ils disent que
c'est quelque chose qui présente
globalement beaucoup moins de risques
que toutes les autres formes de
production d'énergie y compris certaines
formes d'énergie renouvelables puisque
dans les renouvelables il y a les
barrages par exemple et les accidents de
barrage ont tué considérablement plus de
monde sur la planète que les accidents
de centrales nucléaires
déplacé plus de monde construction du
barrage des Trois Gorges a déplacer un
million de personnes Tchernobyl c'est
250000 donc je dis pas que c'est un
anecdote de déplacer 250 000 personnes
je dis juste que l'idée même qui
pourrait y avoir des activités sans
risque à opposer à des activités
risquées quand vous regardez les
chiffres vous vous rendez compte que la
situation est un peu plus compliquée que
ça alors par ailleurs dans les énergies
renouvelables on a des énergies
renouvelables historiques qui sont
notamment le bois hydroélectricité alors
l'hydroélectricité avant
l'hydroélectricité il y avait les
moulins à eau donc la force motrice de
l'eau est quelque chose qu'on utilise
depuis très longtemps sur terre la force
motrice du vent est également quelque
chose qu'on utilise depuis très
longtemps puisque les premiers bateaux
hors galériens ont été propulsés de
cette manière et il y avait des moulins
à vent partout en Europe il y a il y a
quelques siècles
la la les deux renouvelables qui sont
aujourd'hui faciles à utiliser dans le
monde c'est la biomasse et
l'hydroélectricité et du reste quand
vous regardez mais pour ça il faut avoir
des grandes quantités de forêt ou des
grandes quantités de montagne par
habitant alors quand c'est le cas vous
avez des pays qui peuvent avoir un
approvisionnement renouvelable
extrêmement important typiquement la
Norvège la Norvège c'est 5 millions
d'individus sur un pays qui est grand
comme la moitié de la France ça ne pose
pas et plein de montagnes ça ne pose pas
de problème et il consomme 2,5 fois
l'électricité par personne qu'on
consomme nous et c'est 100% renouvelable
donc ça pose pas de problème à cause des
la Suède est un pays où vous n'avez pas
de chauffage au fioul pas de chauffage
au gaz ou quasiment pas c'est un pays
dans lequel une partie de l'électricité
est faite de l'industrie pardon tourne
avec de la biomasse mais à nouveau c'est
un pays avec 10 millions d'habitants sur
350 000 km² la France en fait 550 ce
couvert à 70% de forêt et avec plein de
montagnes donc c'est un pays qui peut
avoir un approvisionnement renouvelable
extrêmement conséquent à partir du
moment où vous vous dirigez vers des
pays qui sont densément peuplés et plat
c'est ça les deux caractéristiques ça
devient considérablement plus difficile
d'avoir un approvisionnement
renouvelable conséquent et là dedans
j'incluse l'Allemagne par exemple qui
malgré les efforts extrêmement
importants ces 20 dernières années
n'arrivent pas à la cheville de la Suède
en ce qui concerne la provisionnement
d'origine renouvelable tout simplement
parce qu'elle est très handicapée par sa
densité démographique et sa géographie
et si je vous parle de la Belgique ils y
arrivent ou des Pays-Bas ils y
arriveront encore moins exactement pour
ces raisons là
c'est bien pour ça du reste que tous ces
pays commencent à parler d'importation
donc il y a une espèce de baguette
magique qui se fait jour qui est les
renouvelables ailleurs je sais pas bien
pourquoi les pays ailleurs feraient des
renouvelables d'abord pour exporter de
l'hydrogène en Allemagne plutôt que de
le faire pour décarboner leur propre
économie il faudra qu'on m'explique pour
le moment j'ai pas bien compris donc si
vous regardez les caractéristiques
physiques des renouvelables encore une
fois vous en avez deux qui
historiquement ont été très facile à
utiliser les droits électricité et le
bois
le vent était moins facile à utiliser
tout simplement parce que c'est pas
pilotable le soleil était moins facile à
le soleil a été extrêmement utilisé tout
simplement pour sécher les récoltes
quand même et pour se chauffer le fait
d'avoir des habitations avec des façades
au sud etc enfin le soleil on s'en est
beaucoup beaucoup servi
le le la civilisation industrielle nous
a donc donné les combustibles fossiles
et avatar des combustibles fossiles nous
avons une nucléaire je dis avatar parce
qu'effectivement il faut de la
métallurgie il faut des mines il faut
des transports etc pour faire des
centrales nucléaires aujourd'hui sans
qu'on puisse aussi vous faites par une
centrale nucléaire pas plus que vous
faites une éolienne moderne
la bonne question c'est à partir du
moment où on compresse le système
énergétique de quoi est-ce qu'on
commence à se débarrasser en premier et
est-ce que on se donne deux objectifs en
même temps on commence par en avoir un
voilà et ma ma vision c'est que on a
plus de chances d'y arriver si on
commence par se donner un objectif et
comme je considère que au sein des
activités industrielles le nucléaires
c'est pas plus risqué que la chimie ça
est plutôt moins et c'est
considérablement moins risqué que les
centrales à charbon je suis plutôt
d'avis que on commence par faire un peu
plus de nucléaires pour supprimer très
vite des centrales à charbon et ensuite
on verra voilà c'est un peu ça mon point
de vue après je
si la volonté démocratique suprême est
de faire un truc 100% e NR et que les
gens ont bien compris les contreparties
qui est que ça va compresser le système
plus vite que si on garde une source
pilotable et concentrée bah si faut-il
mais je suis pas sûr qu'aujourd'hui les
gens aiment bien compris la contrepartie
si je prends l'exemple par exemple de la
compétitivité la positivité j'en reviens
à ce que je disais tout à l'heure on l'a
démontré dans un monde qui ou la
productivité industrielle est dopée au
combustible fossiles qu'est-ce qu'il
reste de cette compétitivité des
énergies renouvelables modernes donc
éolien et solaire dans un monde où il
n'y a plus le Charbon Pour faire la
métallurgie où il n'y a plus le pétrole
pour faire les transports et la mise en
place des dispositifs où il n'y a plus
de pétrole pour faire toute la chimie
organique qui est totalement
indispensable aujourd'hui pour faire des
éoliennes et des panneaux solaires etc
qu'est-ce qui reste de cette
compétitivité des renouvela je n'en sais
rien il Marignac n'en sait rien personne
n'en sait rien parce que c'est un sujet
qui n'a pas du tout été exploré et moi
ce que je dis c'est que tant que ce
sujet n'a pas été exploré faire des
paris pour l'avenir qui postulent le
fait que l'on va garder des prix
extrêmement bas pour les dispositifs je
dis bah c'est un pari qui qui n'est
absolument pas avéré dans les scénarios
de déploiement des ENR que vous avez à
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie par
exemple on postule que la productivité
industrielle permettant de faire ses ENR
reste dans un monde sans combustible
fossile pour alimenter la productivité
industrielle
au premier d'entre eux avant de avant de
s'attaquer au suivant voilà c'est ça mon
c'est ça mon point je suis pas en train
de dire que il faut totalement se passer
de NR ça n'aurait pas de sens je suis
pas en train de dire que le nucléaire
est une solution miracle je ne l'ai
jamais dit je ne le dirai jamais je dis
juste que on se complique un peu plus la
tâche
en refusant de s'emparer aussi de la
solution nucléaire le truc est déjà
tellement titanesque même en utilisant
du nucléaire que si on n'utilise pas je
pense que on augmente la difficulté et
donc on augmente le risque d'aller
ailleurs que là on voudrait aller voilà
c'est ça mon point vous avez commencé
par aborder par le nucléaire par la
sécurité on le voit aujourd'hui avec la
guerre en Ukraine il y a quand même un
risque autour des centrales nucléaires
parce que j'ai dit que on se situerait
entre la Renaissance et quelque chose
comme aujourd'hui en termes de société
avec la décroissance que vous prenez
donc on sait pas si en tant que entente
de guerre civile comme le dit Philippe
bwix comment on va gérer la sécurité des
centrales nucléaires et puis le deuxième
point c'est sur la sécurité
d'approvisionnement aujourd'hui ça vient
du Niger à 30%, comment on gère d'un
point de vue géopolitique
l'approvisionnement des centrales
aujourd'hui notre approvisionnement en
panneau solaire et en éoliennes il y a à
100% de l'étranger donc on est
totalement dépendant de l'étranger sur
cette approvisionnement et sachant que
comme on exploite des énergies diffuses
le vent et le soleil il faut en gros 10
fois plus de métal par kilowatt-heure et
50 fois plus de ciment par kilowattheure
produit le ciment est en produit avec
des énergies fossiles qui sont importés
je je lisais même d'une indépendance
avec des ENR et du chimères ça n'existe
pas quelle que soit la source d'énergie
qu'on va employer en France on sera
dépendant de l'étranger de toute façon
pour des ressources métalliques de toute
façon
en l'occurrence l'uranium la provenance
c'est pas juste le Niger il y en a aussi
on a en Australie etc le principal c'est
une mesure aujourd'hui non la principale
mine d'orano mais c'est pas du tout
notre principal approvisionnement en
France
mais peu importe en ce qui concerne la
vous savez avant avant la guerre en
Ukraine 40% du gaz européen venait de
Russie et il y a 10 ans j'ai fait une
intervention au Sénat où j'avais dit bon
les Russes il nous fournissent 40 pour
le moment c'est nos copains mais on sait
pas si ça va être le cas voilà bon donc
toute approvisionnement en provenance de
l'étranger des questionnables tout
approvisionnement la bonne question
c'est comment est-ce qu'on arrive à
dépendre de gens qui raisonnablement
dépendent aussi un peu de nous de telle
sorte que chacun tient l'autre par la
barbichette et qu'on peut compter sur
une forme de pérennité des échanges
c'est ça la bonne question mais l'idée
que on va se rendre indépendant avec des
moyens qui sont des moyens
technologiquement avancés c'est une
chimère ça n'existe pas pour gérer un
réseau dans lequel vous avez énormément
de sources non pilotables vous avez
besoin d'électronique de puissance
partout aujourd'hui cet électronique de
puissance fait appel à des métaux qui
n'existent pas enfin qui ne sont pas
extraits en France donc par quelques
boucles et puis ne sache que le cuivre
on en extrait pas en France l'Europe
elle n'extrait que 20% du cuivre qu'elle
consomme donc l'idée que on va se rendre
indépendant de l'étranger par un système
électrique plutôt qu'un autre c'est une
idée qu'il faut se sortir de la tête
donc il faut regarder les choses dans le
détail en ce qui concerne la centrale
ukrainienne je vais vous faire la même
réponse que pour la centrale japonaise
de Fukushima le vrai problème c'est la
guerre pour le moment c'est pas la
centrale je vais le dire autrement s'il
y avait un accident dans la centrale de
saporinja ça ne changerait pas grand
chose au bilan sanitaire et
environnemental de la guerre
donc le vrai problème c'est la guerre
sur la sécurité nucléaire parce que
beaucoup de points d'abord sur
sur l'argument de l'indépendance etc on
est évidemment personne ne projette que
ce soit à l'échelle des territoires ou à
l'échelle des pays de stratégie
d'indépendance au sens
d'autonomie totale à travers les
renouvelables ou le nucléaire ou autre
chose la question c'est effectivement la
nature des dépendances ou la nature des
plutôt interdépendances entre des
potentiels et des besoins c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
à négawatts on a travaillé depuis
plusieurs années à un scénario européen
construit
avec des partenaires pour réfléchir à
des trajectoires nationales que l'on a
ensuite agrégé et mutualisé au niveau
européen pour répondre à cette question
effectivement de comment on peut aller
vers 100% renouvelable avec des pays qui
sont qui ont un potentiel pour mobiliser
des énergies renouvelables bien plus
grandes que d'autres à l'échelle
européenne la même chose d'ailleurs vous
sur le plan
[Musique]
les dépendances
liées aux énergies renouvelables sont
quand même par rapport au nucléaire
beaucoup moins importantes du point de
vue technologique d'abord
il n'y a pas d'enjeux de propriété des
technologies et des matières mises en
jeu alors que ça a été historiquement le
facteur limitant pour le déploiement du
nucléaire dans le monde autour de ce
qu'on appelle la risque de prolifération
donc la nature dual civile et militaire
de ces technologies et de ces matières
on pourrait parfaitement si c'était une
décision politique industrielle
relocaliser la production des moyens
photovoltaïques éolien il y a ensuite la
question de la dépendance aux métaux
mais comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure il
y a pas de dépendance critique à des
métaux spécifiques aux énergies
renouvelables dans les scénarios qu'on
peut qu'on peut écrire
et puis
sur le plan de la compétitivité pardon
mais en fait le raisonnement que vous
avez tenu vis-à-vis des renouvelables
vaut autant vis-à-vis du nucléaire
l'enjeu c'est bien de basculer d'une
production aujourd'hui essentiellement
fossile d'énergie au niveau mondial vers
une production des carbonées
la bonne nouvelle de notre point de vue
c'est que les progrès liés aux énergies
révolutions industrielle donc basé sur
les énergies fossiles s'appliquent en
particulier aux énergies renouvelables
le photovoltaïque a gagné un facteur 10
en performance économique ces 10
dernières années l'éolien un facteur 3 à
4 et donc ce qui est devant nous
aujourd'hui c'est peut-être et en tout
cas c'est éminemment souhaitable et même
indispensables vis-à-vis des objectifs
climatiques de réussir de capitaliser en
fait sur ce progrès technique pour faire
fonctionner un système avec ces
renouvelables
le nucléaire dans l'histoire et encore
une fois je laisse de côté le nucléaire
existant je parle de nouveau nucléaires
le nouveau nucléaire étant plus cher et
plus difficile et incertain à déployer
que les renouvelables ne vient pas
faciliter de notre point de vue
l'équation et bien au contraire la
compliquée et voilà notre notre
conviction c'est que projeter dès
aujourd'hui un système 100% renouvelable
et plus sûr et plus
c'est un chemin disons plus praticable
que d'intégrer du nouveau nucléaire dans
la perspective et puis évidemment vous
l'avez dit il y a la question du risque
et là je peux pas vous laisser réduire
la question du nucléaire et de son
risque à simplement une question de
biologie d'abord parce que il y a quand
même aujourd'hui dans les modèles de
relations entre la radioactivité et les
effets sanitaires
tout un en fait tout un corpus qui
repose encore aujourd'hui
essentiellement sur les conséquences
d'Hiroshima et les Nagasaki c'est-à-dire
une irradiation aiguë
liée aux explosions et pas du tout sur
le corpus que l'on fait la science n'a
pas étudié à la fois pour des raisons
pratiques et peut-être pour des raisons
de mauvaises volonté de l'impact de la
catastrophe de Tchernobyl qui elle est
une contamination chronique donc de
nature très différente sur le plan
biologique mais surtout parce que le
risque nucléaire il se joue ailleurs que
dans la comptabilité simplement du
nombre de victimes liées à la
radioactivité moi je ne connais pas dans
une trajectoire 100% renouvelable de
scénarios où l'on perdrait brutalement à
cause d'un accident nucléaire condamnant
une partie du territoire des éléments de
notre patrimoine je sais pas les
châteaux de la Loire la production de
champagne donc le risque
du point de vue du territoire et du
point de vue de notre patrimoine est
différent le risque intergénérationnel
est évidemment différent dans les
scénarios renouvelables on ne l'aide pas
la responsabilité de gérer les déchets
radioactifs comme on le fait dans le
nucléaire et moi je dis souvent que on
trouvera parce qu'il faudra bien une
façon technique de gérer ses déchets
mais que on ne trouvera pas une façon
acceptable éthiquement de le faire
puisque par principe on l'aide cette
responsabilité aux générations futures
et puis il y a l'enjeu de la sécurité
la question de d'installation nucléaire
en France vis-à-vis à la fois des des
besoins d'importation spécifique
d'uranium et vis-à-vis de la
vulnérabilité que ça représente sur
notre territoire et les loin d'être
anodine surtout si on la projette parce
que les sociologues appellent l'horizon
d'attente de d'un programme comme il
nous EPR 2 c'est à dire 30 ans pour les
construire mais
60 ans ensuite pour les exploiter une
centaine d'années ensuite pour gérer
leurs déchets en fait projeter ça c'est
comme si on imaginait ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui vu respectivement de
1990-1930
1840 on voit tout ce qui peut sur le
plan technologique
institutionnel et géopolitique se
passait et donc
le le projet de nouveau réacteur
nucléaire il langage la société
française dans une
nécessité une garantie de maîtrise des
risques associés
voilà beaucoup plus forte beaucoup plus
contraignante qu'un projet basé sur les
renouvelables beaucoup plus flexible
ajustable au fil du temps
c'est de notre point de vue un vrai
choix de société qui aujourd'hui n'est
pas posée puisque l'essentiel du débat
se concentre sur la décarbonation du
système et le mix l'optimum du mix
électrique à l'horizon 2050
la première sur la question de la
compétitivité il est pas légitime de
comparer entre eux deux produits qui
sont pas de la nature donc un
kilowatt-heure éolien ou un
kilowattheure solaire étant fatal c'est
à dire dépendant des conditions
extérieures on ne peut pas les comparer
à 1 kilowattheure venant d'une source
pilotable que ce soit du gaz du charbon
mais je parlais donc ce qu'il faut donc
ce qu'il faut qu'on parle même avec des
hypothèses très optimistes sur les EnR
RTE a quand même dit que le coût complet
d'un système dans lequel il y avait pas
de nucléaire était plus supérieur au
complet d'un système dans lequel il y en
a moyennant un financement ne tenant pas
compte de son risque alors moyennant un
financement qui est-ce qu'il est et
sachant que par ailleurs
la question de la prime de risque
aujourd'hui elle est très élevée dans
justement dans dans les EPR c'est bien
ça qui conduit les le coût du
mégawattheure est très élevé parce qu'il
y a un coup du capital qui est très
élevé
sur la donc il faut regarder les
systèmes complets si on regarde les
systèmes complets il faut rajouter
stockage et réseau et à ce moment tous
les calculs que j'ai vu passer montrent
que l'avantage est au nucléaire tout
simplement parce que le côté pilotable
permet d'éviter tout un tas d'autres
coûts et ses coûts du reste sont
croissants avec le pourcentage de
pénétration après on peut regarder un
exemple historique également l'Allemagne
à date elle a mis à peu près 500
milliards d'euros dans le déploiement de
son solaire et de son éolien pour faire
à peu près 30% de son électricité
aujourd'hui sachant que le coup
historique du parc nucléaire français
c'est plutôt 150 milliards d'euros pour
faire quelque chose qui se rapproche des
trois quarts en condition normal de la
production électrique donc on voit bien
que et l'Allemagne dans le dans le dans
le contexte dans lequel elle est
aujourd'hui si on fermait ses frontières
électriques je dis bien si on fermait
ses frontières électriques de temps en
temps le système exposerait parce que la
volatilité qui a maintenant à
l'intérieur du système est devenu trop
importante
donc ce qu'il faut je le redis c'est
comparer des coûts complets si on veut
aller sur ce terrain là sur la question
de l'horizon de temps avec les EnR on
prend tout autant à Paris puisque une
fois qu'on installe un système c'est pas
pour le détricoter le lendemain donc en
fait on prend tout autant le pari que à
long terme on va continuer à avoir un
approvisionnement en métaux suffisant en
provenance de l'étranger qu'on va avoir
de quoi compenser en permanence
l'intermittence qu'on induit dans le
système avec des dispositifs qui donc on
prend éventuellement le pari par exemple
on va réussir à faire des stations de
pompage partout dans les Alpes ou qu'on
va avoir des batteries partout où on
prend le pari que il y a de l'activité
économique qui va devenir extrêmement
flexible et qu'on va arriver à organiser
le système sans problème ce que
aujourd'hui on n'est pas capable de
démontrer donc en fait on prend des
paris quel que soit la voie qu'on
choisisse l'idée de dire il y a un pari
sans risque et un pari avec risque c'est
pareil de toute façon dans le monde dans
lequel on se dirige il y a des risques
il va y en avoir partout donc la bonne
question c'est de savoir comment est-ce
dont on parle les deux on peut pas dire
que il y a pas eu d'analyse des effets
chroniques de la radioactivité il y a eu
un corpus d'études médicales sur les
conséquences de Tchernobyl extrêmement
dense et du reste ça a donné lieu à des
rapports publiés par
c'est-à-dire les Nations Unies qui les a
rejetées
par un je sais pas du tout d'accord on
n'a pas dû dire les mêmes rapports donc
les il y a c'est un rapport qui est fait
exactement comme le rapport du GIEC
c'est-à-dire qu'en compile toutes les
analyses épidémiologiques qui ont été
faites et qui dit voilà ce qu'on peut
dire et voilà ce qu'on peut pas dire et
c'est absolument pas un rejet c'est pas
plus que le GIEC rejette quoi que ce
soit le géant justement je suis d'accord
que les deux organismes ont eu des
attitudes complètement posées vis-à-vis
de faisceaux de présomption il faudra
m'envoyer la référence de l'unescare qui
s'est déduit lui-même parce que j'ai
jamais vu ça donc je suis désolé ça
n'existe pas
et quand on regarde les analyses qui ont
été faites par lunchcare temps sur
Tchernobyl que sur Fukushima
il y a des conclusions qui sont
extrêmement claires Fukushima il y a pas
eu un mort à cause du surplus de
radioactivité donc il y a eu des morts à
cause de l'évacuation donc la bonne
question c'est qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
qu'on a comme politique d'évacuation si
jamais on a un pépin c'est ça la bonne
question et en ce qui concerne
Tchernobyl il y a des conclusions qui
sont également extrêmement précises dans
des rapports qui font des centaines de
pages qui qui disent ce qu'on a observé
et ce qu'on n'a pas observé bon
donc on peut pas dire que il y a pas de
il y a juste les Cortes dire au Shima il
Nagasaki qui servent à faire des
analyses sur les effets de la
radioactivité induit par ailleurs vous
avez énormément de la
Commission de protection contre les
rayonnements ionisants c'est un truc qui
a un siècle donc on peut pas dire que
c'est il n'y a pas il y a pas de matière
première justement
sur ce genre d'effet il y en a et du
reste il y a également des analyses qui
montrent que les la radioactivité à
faible dose pourrait avoir un effet de
type vaccination c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'effet d'ormessis
voilà donc
il y a un débat là-dessus moi je suis
pas en train de dire que c'est prouvé
mais par contre ce que je sais c'est
qu'il y a de la production de
littérature médicale sur la question et
que il y a tout à fait des informations
qui sont accessibles là-dessus si on
veut comparer le nucléaire avec d'autres
industries je veux dire il y a plein
d'autres industries pour lesquelles les
effets sont avérés de manière beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus importante
sur la sur la comparaison de la des
effets sanitaires directs et indirects
entre les diverses formes de production
électrique là aussi il y a de la
littérature médicale qui est disponible
depuis un certain temps donc quand on
regarde
l'information technique qui est
disponible je le redis et l'information
économique qui est disponible je ne vois
pas moi davantage évident à un système
qui est basé sur l'exploitation
d'énergie diffuse et non pilotable et du
coup il y a un risque qui est associé à
cette option là c'est celui de ne pas y
arriver et du coup de faire exactement
ce qu'on fait les Allemands c'est à dire
que ils sont sortis du nucléaire les EnR
ça va pas assez vite et du coup ils ont
toujours leur centrales à la limite donc
il y a un risque absolument évident à
choisir une voie
qui est trop ambitieuse pour les moyens
qu'on va avoir
c'est de conserver plus longtemps des
choses qui sont bien pires que le
nucléaire
ce risque il est il est il existe
tellement qu'aujourd'hui c'est celui qui
se matérialise tous les jours
aujourd'hui c'est celui qui se
matérialise tous les jours et justement
pour parler de risque pour le futur Yves
Marignac vous posez la question éthique
par rapport aux déchets je sais pas si
vous avez lu la BD d'Étienne davodo sur
le droit du sol non je l'ai pas lu je
sais qu'il nous doit d'avoir augmenté
ses ventes par rapport et en fait sans
fin serait pas sorti mais
juste une question
la sémiologie en fait je vais vous
répondre c'est pas tellement la quantité
c'est la question éthique oui je vais
bien sûr alors d'abord je pense que la
quantité ça joue on peut pas dire c'est
pas une question de quantité ça joue
nécessairement
donc la question des déchets est la
suivante pour moi c'est
dans tous les cas de figure on l'aide à
nos descendants une situation avec des
points d'interrogation
la dérive climatique qu'on va laisser à
nos descendants va de toute façon durer
des milliers d'années quoi qu'on fasse
en matière d'émission par exemple la
hausse du niveau de la mer c'est quelque
chose qui va s'échelonner sur des
milliers d'années quoi qu'on fasse il y
a des situations donc donc l'idée même
que on pourrait l'aider à nos
descendants une situation dans laquelle
tout est sous contrôle je dis non
malheureusement il faut se sortir cette
idée de la tête ça n'est malheureusement
plus possible
là dedans quelle est la part que joue
les déchets nucléaires la question qu'il
faut se poser c'est est-ce qu'on est
capable de léguer à nos descendants une
situation que eux-mêmes seront capables
de léguer à leur descendance dans une
situation sous contrôle c'est ça la
bonne question donc l'idée que on va
léguer à nos descendants une situation
dans laquelle toute nuisance a été
supprimée je dis malheureusement c'est
trop tard c'est il aurait fallu s'y
prendre avant pour ça ça c'est quelque
chose qui n'arrivera pas est-ce que en
matière de déchets on leur laisse une
situation qui est potentiellement hors
de contrôle ma réponse c'est pas plus
que sur plein d'autres domaines dans
plein d'autres domaines et donc plutôt
moins et en particulier
il y a une anecdote géologique qu'on
peut citer pour remettre les déchets
dans leur dans leur perspectives il y a
au Gabon une mine d'uranium qui
s'appelle oclo
et dans laquelle sont apparus il y a 2
milliards d'années des réacteurs
naturels alors ces réacteurs naturels
ils avaient été prédit par la théorie et
ils sont arrivés parce que outlaw donc
c'est un endroit où il y a un gisement
d'uranium il y a deux milliards d'années
la teneur en uranium 235 dans l'uranium
naturel et les 3%
3,5% tout simplement parce que l'uranium
235 il a eu demi-vie d'à peu près 700
800 millions d'années
et donc avec des infiltrations d'eau
qu'il y a eu en provenance de la surface
il y a des réacteurs qui sont
spontanément mis en route
ils ont évidemment fait des déchets ils
ont fait des produits de fission ils ont
fait des trans Uraniens ils ont fait
donc ils ont fait des déchets et
l'analyse géologique qui est faite une
situation montre que ces déchets ont
extrêmement peu migrés par rapport à
leur endroit de formation en 2 milliards
d'années
donc il faut savoir par ailleurs que
dans les déchets l'essentiel de la
radioactivité est concentré dans les
produits de fission et que les produits
de fission ils durent pas sans bidon il
durent beaucoup moins que ça dure
quelques en gros au bout de quelques
siècles l'essentiel de leur
radioactivité a disparu donc la question
c'est est-ce qu'il existe des formations
géologiques
où les choses vont pas durer 2 milliards
d'années mais vont durer suffisamment
longtemps que ça va ça va rester confiné
suffisamment longtemps pour que on
puisse être tranquille des formations
géologiques que vous êtes capable de
confiner des choses très longtemps ça
existe et je vais vous prendre un
exemple c'est une réservoir de pétrole
un réservoir de pétrole ça contient un
truc qui est sous pression et liquide
donc c'est quand même un peu plus
difficile à garder au même endroit que
des déchets nucléaires qui sont solides
et pourtant dans ce genre de formation
géologique vous avez des choses qui
peuvent rester en place sans bouger
pendant des millions d'années donc
l'idée que on va faire un trou et mettre
les déchets qui nous enquiquinent dans
un trou personnellement c'est pas ça qui
me paraît être le risque majeur que nous
courons et dans tout ce qu'on peut
laisser à nos descendants le fait de
répondre des phytosanitaires partout le
fait de mettre du CO2 dans l'atmosphère
le fait d'avoir de la pollution chimique
chronique absolument partout avec des
perturbateurs endocriniens qui se
baladent partout etc ça me perturbe
beaucoup plus que la question des
déchets nucléaires voilà si je fais une
hiérarchie parce que on ne peut pas ne
pas compter on ne peut pas dire
tout esthétiquement comparable dès lors
que vous avez un truc qui perdure dans
le temps non c'est pas exactement pareil
sur les déchets globalement bien sûr que
des pollutions chroniques bien sûr que
des déchets accumulés et moi j'appelle
souvent à ce qu'on est la même
précaution ou la même la même
préoccupation vis-à-vis des déchets
chimiques dangereux que vis-à-vis des
déchets nucléaires il y a des déchets
chimiques dangereux pour lesquels l'État
demande juste aujourd'hui une servitude
de 30 ans c'est pas sérieux vis-à-vis du
risque à long terme
donc bien sûr on va léguer des risques
des incertitudes et des points
d'interrogation le fait qu'il y en ait
beaucoup n'est pas une excuse pour en
laisser spécifiquement quelques-uns si
on peut si on peut les éviter c'est
vraiment ça tout le point c'est à dire
que si aujourd'hui on projette le fait
que d'un côté une trajectoire à l'envers
100% renouvelable et faisable qu'une
trajectoire où on ajoute du nucléaire je
pense notre point principal de
divergence une trajectoire où on ajoute
du nouveau nucléaire est une trajectoire
en réalité
moins assurée qu'une trajectoire où on
organise le système pour aller vers 100%
renouvelable moins assuré parce que il y
a une forme d'incompatibilité dans le
fonctionnement du système entre le
nucléaire qui est un truc lourd
centralisé en base et un fonctionnement
100% renouvelable moins assuré parce que
dans le cas des renouvelables on déploie
des options différentes à des échelles
très différentes on le déploie beaucoup
plus vite les le taux de renouvellement
des projets est plus gros et donc c'est
globalement beaucoup plus flexible
ajustable et beaucoup moins irréversible
et les réacteurs nucléaires pardon mais
entre la défaillance du parc nucléaire
cet hiver avec 15 réacteurs arrêtés à
cause d'un problème de sûreté générique
qui n'avait pas été anticipé et le
dixième retard le dixième hiver de
retard malheureusement de de Flamanville
la preuve que parier sur le nucléaire
engendre un risque de fiabilité pour la
trajectoire électrique est faite donc si
on considère que se projeter vers le
100% renouvelable est en réalité compte
tenu des progrès et de l'innovation dans
ce domaine plus praticable et plus sûr
il n'y a aucune raison d'embarquer avec
soi des risques et des incertitudes
supplémentaires comme ceux de l'accident
nucléaire qui peut se produire à tout
moment et qui ne se comptabilise pas que
en nombre immédiat de morts comme le
problème intergénérationnel de la
gestion des déchets et comme les enjeux
de sécurité et d'interdépendance
géopolitique associée à cette forme
d'énergie qui lui sont extrêmement
spécifiques on voit que le sujet est
complexe donc on va peut-être finir par
la bonne question comme vous dites
Jean-Marc c'est comment on choisit
est-ce avons choisi en faisant confiance
au peuple c'est-à-dire la démocratie
est-ce que ce sont des techniciens qui
décident une élite qui décide pour finir
cet entretien c'est comment on décide
entre les deux peut-être détails qui
vous opposent parce que globalement vous
êtes plutôt d'accord et ça j'en suis
plutôt content c'est comment choisir
aujourd'hui vous avez parlé de ce qui se
passe dans notre cervelle les gens qui
nous regardent vont peut-être avoir des
réactions différentes en vous écoutant
l'un et l'autre c'est comment on choisit
en fait aujourd'hui
le mandat de la démocratie c'est de
faire reposer sur le peuple le choix des
représentants
c'est pas nécessairement de faire
reposer sur le peuple le choix de chaque
décision prise de manière unitaire là
quand vous voyez les divers systèmes
démocratiques qui existent dans le monde
vous avez des variantes donc vous avez
des la France est un pays particulier
parce que c'est un pays dans lequel
l'exécutif a énormément de pouvoir si
vous prenez à l'autre extrémité du
spectre vous allez trouver les
États-Unis ou l'exécutif a extrêmement
peu de pouvoir et où c'est l'appareil
législatif qui a tous les pouvoirs et en
fait il a
tellement de pouvoir et il est renouvelé
tellement fréquemment que en fait il se
passe à peu près rien enfin c'est une
société très immobile les États-Unis en
termes de corpus de corpus législatif et
réglementaire
puis au milieu vous avez les Suisses par
exemple avec leur système de votation
etc tout ça c'est des variantes de la
démocratie il y a quand même un point
commun dans toutes ces dans toutes ces
variantes c'est le fait que le peuple
choisi ces représentants si le peuple
voulait choisir vous les tenir le crayon
de ces représentants sur chaque décision
que les représentants ont à prendre à ce
moment on se retrouverait dans un
système totalement ingérable enfin en
tout cas aujourd'hui parce que quand
vous regardez le nombre de décisions que
les représentants ont à prendre vous
vous rendez compte que d'avoir un débat
précédent chacune de ces décisions
avec ça tient pas dans des journées 24
heures donc c'est à un moment il faut
voilà donc le choix me semble-t-il
c'est très difficile de sortir d'un
modèle de démocratie représentative si
on veut avoir un système qui prennent
des décisions bon aujourd'hui à chaque
fois que j'entends c'est un débat non
démocratique moi j'ai toujours envie de
le traduire en c'est un débat quel que
soit sa forme qui aboutit à une
conclusion qui n'est pas la mienne en
général c'est un peu comme ça qu'il faut
voir un débat non non démocratique
la démocratie par ailleurs elle a un
effet de bord non négligeable qui est
que c'est un système qui gère du temps
court
c'est difficile d'en sortir donc je dis
pas qu'il faut sortir de la démocratie
mais il faut avoir bien présent à
l'esprit le fait que on a cette
inconvénient qui est très fort et qui
avait été mis en avant par les premiers
observateurs des premières démocraties
puisque des tocles villes vous trouvez
ça dans le dans les observations qui
faisaient en disant c'est un système qui
gère le temps court
or là on est sur des sujets du temps
long c'est-à-dire la modification d'un
système la modification de l'aménagement
du territoire la modification des
pratiques agricoles la modification du
système industriel la modification d'un
système énergétique et la modification
d'un système de valeurs tout ça c'est
sur du temps long
donc c'est difficile de conjuguer les
deux je personnellement j'ai pas trouvé
la réponse à toutes les questions dans
dans cette affaire là
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que tant qu'on
reste dans un système démocratique
en fait le vrai la vraie question elle
est de modifier ce qui se passe dans la
serviette les électeurs plus que de
modifier ce qui se passe dans la tête
des élus je le redis à partir du moment
je vais prendre un exemple tout bête en
ce moment on a une manifestation sur la
réforme des retraites personne dans le
pays ne dit il faut supprimer les
retraites donc on est en train de se
chicaner sur la manière de gérer le
système mais il y a un consensus
absolument parfait sur le fait que le
système est pertinent bon ce qui veut
dire que vous n'allez avoir aucun élu
qui va vous dire moi je veux supprimer
les retraites tout simplement parce que
la base électorale n'en a pas envie donc
dans le sujet qui nous concerne je pense
qu'il y a malheureusement ou
heureusement pas d'autres manières de
s'y prendre que de s'occuper de ce que
pensent le corps électoral parce qu'à
partir du moment où le corps électoral a
des souhaits consensuels sur un certain
nombre de choses derrière ça suivra au
niveau de ses représentants
pour le moment je n'ai pas spéculer sur
ce qui se passerait si on sort de la
démocratie ce qui est un risque ce qui
est un risque parce que quand vous
regardez quand est-ce que la démocratie
est apparue vous vous rendez compte
qu'elle est apparue dans des univers en
croissance ça c'est une remarque que je
m'étais faite en Europe le premier pays
à avoir basculé dans la démocratie c'est
la Grande-Bretagne qui est aussi le
premier pays à avoir basculé dans
l'industrialisation et la croissance et
au fil du temps vous vous rendez compte
que les démocraties populaires pas les
démocraties restreintes à quelques
heureux élus comme ces câbles dire comme
chez les Romains où les Athéniens que
les démocraties populaires c'est-à-dire
concernant l'ensemble des gens sont
apparus dans des pays en croissance et
donc il y a un vrai point
d'interrogation pour moi qui est de
savoir comment est-ce que on fait
perdurer ce genre de système politique
dans des dans des univers dans lesquels
la croissance matérielle n'existe plus
et j'ai pas la réponse une étude de
l'ADN qui est sorti en janvier 2023 57%
des Français sont pris un changement de
système donc comment on arrive à
convaincre les politiques d'embrayer sur
cette dynamique citoyenne cette question
cette question de la dynamique
démocratique du choix elle est à la fois
essentielle et très difficile
peut-être aussi difficile que la
question des changements économiques
moins difficiles à mon sens sauf si on
parle de démocratie mondiale que la
question géopolitique que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure c'est un impensé pour moi
de la transition écologique que ça remet
en cause l'ensemble des relations
géopolitiques et c'est pour moi le
principal obstacle à la mise en œuvre de
ces transformations mais du point de vue
démocratique en revenant à l'échelle
d'un pays comme le nôtre c'est
la démocratie c'est à la fois un
impératif et une difficulté
vis-à-vis de ce qui nous concerne c'est
un impératif d'abord parce que
parce que c'est vital ça fait partie des
objectifs de développement soutenable de
conserver et même de renforcer la
gouvernance démocratique c'est vital
aussi parce que la dictature en fait
historiquement n'a jamais été un système
de captation du pouvoir dans l'intérêt
général donc une dictature verte auquel
à laquelle certains appellent parfois je
ne sais pas moi quoi je ne crois pas que
ça puisse exister et tant mieux parce
que fondamentalement la démocratie doit
être doit être la boussole une fois
qu'on a dit ça effectivement toute la
difficulté c'est que on a à la fois
besoin de conserver une démocratie
représentative un système national qui
soit capable de dépasser la question des
intérêts particuliers et de projeter le
temps long on a besoin d'une forme de
planification dans la durée des
transformations parce que sans ça on
n'aura pas la cohérence et l'efficience
indispensable mais on a aussi besoin que
cette démocratie devienne beaucoup plus
horizontale et que en fait la transition
pourrait être mise en œuvre dans la
mesure où elle repose sur des
changements locaux de mobilité de
bâtiments d'aménagement du territoire
sur des mobilisations locales d'énergie
renouvelable
tout ça doit se faire au niveau des
acteurs locaux avec des formes nouvelles
et donc on a besoin d'une appropriation
très horizontale par chacun des enjeux
et des solutions avec la difficulté du
temps nécessaire à cette à cette
appropriation mais
là pour nous il y a pas d'autre chemin
que celui là et effectivement
c'est on le voit dans notre pays plus
difficile plus difficile que dans
d'autres pays parce que notre tradition
hyper centralisatrice et assez
technocratique s'oppose effectivement à
cette à cette démarche transverse et
horizontale et d'une certaine manière le
débat sur le nucléaire aujourd'hui et en
miroir le débat sur les renouvelables je
pense qu'on est le seul pays où il est
un tel niveau de d'opposition et même
d'hostilité parfois viscérale
aux énergies renouvelables traduit bien
cette difficulté à sortir d'un modèle
démocratique dans lequel le nucléaire a
bénéficié jusqu'ici d'une place à part
institutionnellement avec des règles de
droit avec des mécanismes avec des
institutions qui lui sont spécifiques et
on le voit
encore aujourd'hui avec les débats en
cours et un certain nombre de blocages
au point que la Commission du débat
public en charge du débat sur les
nouveaux EPR à suspendu le cours normal
du débat pour consacrer les quelques
jours qui lui restent à cette question
centrale du rapport entre nucléaire et
démocratie on arrive à la fin de ce
débat dans une conférence que vous avez
donné à Genève je crois Jean-Marc la
dernière question dans l'auditoire
c'était pensez-vous que le système
chinois serait plus performant pour une
transition énergétique j'aimerais avoir
votre réponse aujourd'hui en janvier
la mauvaise nouvelle est probablement
oui
une nouvelle est probablement oui
ça renvoie à ce qu'on vient de se dire
sur le fait que une fois qu'on a élu des
représentants
on a matériellement pas le temps si on
veut être efficace de leur tenir le
stylo sur toute décision qui serait
amené à prendre derrière c'est juste une
question de temps
et en ce moment je vais prendre un
exemple il y a une commission d'enquête
de l'Assemblée sur la perte de
souveraineté et d'indépendance
énergétique de la France alors moi je le
prends comme une chaîne d'information
parce que ok vous avez participé
tous les deux super intéressant parce
qu'il y a des il y a des auditions de
trois heures etc bon c'est ils en sont à
plus de points c'est un point parmi des
milliers
des travaux parlementaires parce que si
je voulais avoir un avis éclairé sur les
décisions de la nation sur les tarifs
douaniers sur les importations textiles
sur la façon dont on fabrique les
lunettes sur la PAC sur je sais pas quoi
je devrais passer à chaque fois des
centaines d'heures à écouter ce genre de
choses histoire bon donc en fait c'est
matériellement c'est juste
matériellement impossible donc à un
moment on est obligé d'avoir des gens
qui décident pour nous et le système
chinois il a une caractéristique c'est
que les gens qui décident pour nous ils
vont enfin qui décident pour les Chinois
plus exactement vont un peu plus vite
dans leur processus de décision que ce
qui se passe dans des endroits où on
revient éternellement sur la ce qu'on le
fait qu'il faut faire ou pas faire
et on voit bien que il y a des pays où
ce système est tellement paroxysmique je
pensais aux États-Unis où ils sont
incapables de gérer ce qui leur porte
tort tellement justement l'appareil est
incapable de décider de modifications
structurelles parce que on revient donc
il s'agisse aux Etats-Unis des opiacés
des armes de l'obésité ou qu'est-ce que
je sais vous avez un milliard de trucs
dont vu de l'extérieur vous vous dites
il faudrait vraiment changer ça et en
fait c'est juste impossible précisément
parce que le système il est fait pour
que une fois que vous avez élu vous
représentants vous leur teniez le stylo
derrière sur la totalité des décisions
qui sont qui sont prêtes à prendre
donc c'est ce que je dis peut paraître
un peu provocant dans le fait que si je
t'aime chinois et donc je suis pas en
train de dire que je souhaite un système
chinois en France et pas du tout ça que
je suis en train de dire mais si j'étais
un martien et que je regarde froidement
ceux qui se passe sur terre je
constaterai que un système très
dirigiste sur les enjeux de long terme
et bien ma foi il est plus à l'aise
alors c'est un système très dirigiste
peut faire des conneries majeures c'est
plus facile aussi pour lui de faire des
conneries majeures l'histoire nous en a
donné des exemples tragiques en Europe
il y a quelques décennies donc je le
redis je suis pas du tout en train de
dire que je souhaite un système comme ça
mais par contre je vais dire autrement
ça serait une erreur que de penser que
parce que le régime chinois est très
autoritaire
en matière de transition énergétique il
va nécessairement faire que des
conneries voilà je pense que ça c'est
une erreur de lecture qu'il faut pas
faire alors peut-être pour rebondir sur
ce que vient de dire jean-marjancovici
est-ce que c'est pas si donner du grain
moudre aux réactionnaires qui vous
traitent de mer verte tous les deux avec
cette vision de de décision un peu
rigide sur les j'insiste je suis pas en
train de dire je sais mieux que le
système qu'on a bien compris je me suis
juste en train de dire il faut faire
attention
si vous analysez froidement les choses
à ne pas attribuer à ce système des
défauts qu'il n'a pas sachant qu'il en a
plein d'autres
alors si on laisse de côté
l'aspect non démocratique du régime
chinois qui évidemment n'est pas
souhaitable d'importer je crois que en
fait la Chine bénéficie aujourd'hui de
caractéristiques essentielles dont la
France a notamment bénéficié au moment
où elle a lancé son programme nucléaire
et tout un tas d'autres infrastructures
essentielles à son économie c'est un un
gouvernement qui peut prendre des
décisions de long terme parce que le
consensus
politique et suffisant pour engager des
trajectoires sur sur des décennies donc
parler d'ailleurs en France à l'époque
du Commissariat au Plan qui avait une
vraie fonction à cette époque là et de
une économie en très forte croissance au
sens où on entendait tout à l'heure et
donc on très forte capacité d'investir
dans ces infrastructures c'est
quelque chose que je pense que sur ces
deux plans en fait aujourd'hui la France
n'a pas les moyens aujourd'hui de de
lancer cette transition
il y a un travail il y a la question
économique on en a déjà discuté sur le
plan politique moi je considère que ça
fait plus de 10 ans que en France
notamment à cause du blocage autour du
débat sur le nucléaire et c'est bien
qu'on arrive effectivement en discuter
même si on a pu constater qu'on avait
encore une divergence très forte sur ce
sur cette question en fait ce point avec
tout ce qu'il
engendre historiquement culturellement
économiquement est un obstacle
aujourd'hui très clairement à au
déploiement au développement d'une
vision partagée de la transition
écologique juste socialement porteuse de
bénéfices et tant qu'on n'aura pas cette
vision partagée on n'aura pas les des
électeurs suffisamment convergents sur
ce sujet pour
pouvoir déléguer à nos représentants de
de
mener ces politiques sans tenir le stylo
à tout bout de champ même si le principe
de participation du public aux décisions
ayant un impact en matière
d'environnement qui est adossé à la
Constitution et pour nous quelque chose
de fondamental donc vous parliez des
conservateurs aujourd'hui on a tout un
tas d'acteurs dont le champ politique
qui parce que il s'accroche au fait de
conserver le nucléaire comme pilier de
notre politique énergétique s'oppose à
tout déploiement des renouvelables
s'oppose souvent à la question de la
sobriété et
tant qu'on n'aura pas effectivement
renverser ça et je pense que les
électeurs situés l'étude de l'ADEME on
pourrait citer la convention citoyenne
pour le climat je pense que dès lors que
ils sont suffisamment placés en
conditions de libératives nos
concitoyens comprennent bien mieux
souvent que les politiques tout ces
enjeux mais effectivement la fracture de
la société française sur ces questions
aujourd'hui est un facteur
mortel d'immobilisme qu'il faut voilà
qu'il faudra des résoudre et le type de
conversation que nous avons aujourd'hui
pourra j'espère permettre de progresser
merci le temps est une horreur une
denrée rare mais vous dit Jean-Marc donc
on va arrêter même s'il y avait encore
moult question juste peut-être une
question de conclusion est-ce que vous
avez appris quelque chose dans le
discours de Jean-Marc qui vous a séduit
et inversement est-ce que vous avez
appris quelque chose dans le discours de
Yves qui vous a séduit Yves pour
commencer
j'aime bien votre question
parce que ça change de quelle est la
bonne raison que vous avez de lui taper
dessus voilà c'est un peu la philosophie
Kaizen non non je pense
je savais qu'on avait évidemment une
convergence sur sur les constats je
pense que la convergence est plus
profonde que en tout cas tel qu'on l'a
tel qu'on l'a exprimé que que je
l'imaginais et j'ai noté en particulier
une évolution du discours vis-à-vis des
renouvelables par rapport à un certain
nombre de positions publiques ces
dernières années où ces derniers mois
vous aviez même appelé à un moratoire je
crois à un moment donné et voilà ça je
trouve que c'est vraiment un mouvement
dans le bon sens parce que tous les
scénarios quels qu'ils soient nous
disent que indépendamment du choix
nucléaire on a besoin de déployer les
renouvelables et on a besoin de sobriété
en tout cas voilà moi j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup apprécié cet échange c'est
difficile à chaud d'en retenir un point
particulier mais
Jean-Marc est-ce que vous avez quelque
chose à retenir de cet échange puisque
vous aimez bien la question
non moi ce que je d'abord je suis
content qu'on puisse discuter sans se
traiter de nos oiseaux donc ça c'est
toujours un truc agréable je suis tout à
fait d'accord avec Yves Marignac quand
on dit que le nucléaire a occupé une
place excessive dans les débats et que
du coup ça empêché de discuter de plein
d'autres choses qui sont au moins aussi
essentielles sinon plus
alors je sais pas si c'est une bonne
surprise ou une mauvaise surprise mais
j'ai envie de dire dans ce qui nous
rapproche et ce qui nous éloigne j'ai
envie de dire que les 6 on prend le moto
de nagawatt c'est à dire sobriété
efficacité renouvelable
on est d'accord sur les deux premiers
termes qui sont pour moi les termes
essentiels et on peut éventuellement
discuter du troisième ou c'est
renouvelable des carbonnés etc et ça
doit rester me semble-t-il une
discussion un peu factuelle
à la base pour savoir
sur quoi on est est d'accord pas
d'accord etc et je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec lui également sur le fait
que on embarque pas des dirigeants dans
une démocratie sans avoir d'abord
embarqué les gens qui votent et donc
c'est notre métier à tous les deux c'est
d'essayer de réfléchir à c'est quoi la
construction qui va faire en sorte que
les gens ont envie d'y adhérer
voilà c'est ça le c'est ça c'est ça le
le cahier des charges et donc je retiens
de cette discussion que c'est
intéressant d'en discuter avec des gens
qui travaillent dans la même direction
quel que soit les options qui peuvent
avoir leur préférence par rapport à
celle que on peut avoir sur la main
merci Maria merci cher internaute je
vous souhaite une bonne réflexion par
rapport à ce choix de transition proposé
par nos deux invités au revoir
[Musique]